this is the Joo underground podcast
number 84 sitting here with Echo Charles
and uh there's a I guess it's a little
bit of a corporate buzzword you hear
from time to time change
management so my initial foray into
change management someone asked me about
it 10 years ago when I first was talking
to companies about leadership and they
asked me about what I had for change
management and I immediately said oh
well change management what we have for
change management is the four laws of
combat leadership cover Move simple
prioritize next decentralized command we
talked through how these things apply to
change management and how that's what it
takes to to manage change is
leadership leadership is leadership
whether you're implementing change
whether you're moving forward on a new
project what doesn't matter what you're
doing the leadership principles are the
same there's no there's no separate and
distinct methodology for change
management it's leadership what do you
do you make sure you're mutually support
supporting each other that's cover and
move you keep things simple so people
understand what's happening with the
change you prioritize and execute you
figure out what are the most important
parts of the change that you have to get
done and then you do those first and you
move through that prioritize and execute
and decentralize command which means you
Empower your subordinates you make sure
everyone understands why they're doing
what they're doing you make sure they
understand why this change is happening
this is not this is what we do and we've
taken many companies now through all
aspects of change
management very
effective now I the reason I'm think I
was thinking about this is because again
someone asked me a question about it I
went through this but then I started
talk thinking
about change in in an even broader
perspective because we are constantly as
human beings doing change management in
life right things are going to change
and they can just like change management
can trip up companies or jam up
companies as you might like to say just
as change management can cause those
kind of issues in a company change in
life can trip people up can jam people
up and and I and what I think is look
there's things are going to change we
know that
factually some things are going to
change whether you want them to or not
they're going to
change some things you can slow down
from
changing some things you can actually
stop from Chang in some things you have
to make the change some things you want
to make them
change
so even though we often categorize
things all these different types of
change we categorize them all as just
change but they're not the
same they're not the same at all so
treating change as if all change is the
same is a big mistake and I think a lot
of people people make this mistake when
you look at something in the
world does that thing want to
change can it be changed do I need to
change it how much work will it take to
change it what's the ROI on that work
that it's going to take to change that
thing do I have the time resources
energy investment to make that change
happen and again what am I going to get
out of
it so my point in saying this is that I
think people get tripped up by change
because they don't understand the nature
of the
change so in some cases they fight hard
against changes that cannot be
stopped or they expect changes to happen
without any
effort in areas of change where only
effort and exertion will cause the
change and we have to be careful you
this is the kind of things let me put it
in a Jiu-Jitsu perspective you have to
learn in Jiu-Jitsu that there's certain
positions at a certain point you've
given up you've you've lost the position
and you need to move on you need to
transition to escape you've already lost
the position you need to transition to
escape you also learn in jiujitsu
there's some positions you have to hold
on to as much as you possibly
can there's often times when it comes to
change when we have a closed mind when
it should be open or we have an open
mind when it should be closed and we
accept things that should not be
accepted or we don't accept things that
should be
accepted so what I would like you to do
is as you look at life as you look at
the world recognize that there is
different types of change you can't
treat it all the same you have to be
aware in order order to do that yes
guess what you're going to have to do
you're going to have to detach you're
going to have to take a step back maybe
that means simple drill on Detachment is
writing things down when there's change
happening you need to write down what is
happening why it's happening what the
outcome it could
be whether it's good whether it's
bad and I think if you start to assess
the type of change that you are facing
it is an element that has to be dealt
with but has to be dealt with in
different ways for different occasions
and that's what I would recommend you
learn and understand about change and if
you do that you will be able to
negotiate it
better that's what I've got why are you
smiling cuz it's because it makes sense
it's so true bro and I dig it
where you know like we have our little
Comfort zones and we got our little
routines that we really get used to you
know I'm used to the world working like
this for me and with me and you know and
even if the world's working against me
like I can at least I can manage it cuz
I know what to expect on that one yeah
and then like things start changing you
know and it gets uncomfortable and yeah
the whole fighting thing is kind of like
waves right where you going to fight
that wave you can't fight you literally
cannot fight a wave you can go under it
you can ride it bro you can ride
out of a wave you got to decide put
yourself in the right position got to
decide it's going to be risky a little
bit you know but once you get good at
right waves in general bro you're kind
of down for those waves yep it's like a
skill you can kind of in a way
develop to accommodate the change to
ride the change that's inevitably coming
yes and yet if you fight those waves and
your mindset is just to fight the waves
you're going to lose drown by the way
you're going to drown yeah and and and
that's a perspective thing you're
looking at those things going I need to
fight these things when what reality is
you need to open your mind and say all
right I need to at least roll with them
and if I do really well with an open
mind I can ride these things and take
advantage of these
waves so yeah Jiu-Jitsu surfing combat
life like there's some things that'll
happen on the battlefield you can't stop
it and the more you try and stop it the
more you're giving up and the worse
you're going to be yeah and there's
other situations where change you need
to enable it you need to push it along
yeah but we just categorize it as like
change management that's what we're
doing yeah so
no that's
taking a step back and detaching and
more technically in this situation
writing down what's happening and why
it's happening and then and then
figuring out a way to work through it
that's my
recommendation that change
management there you go think about
think about what's going on in your life
what's giving you trouble it's probably
some kind of
change and then analyze what kind of
change it is analyze why it's why it's
harming you why it's putting you in a
bad situ figure that out
that's what we're doing all right let's
get to some Q&A Q&A from NOCO Bo NOCO
yeah U Jo what do you think of the
statements if you don't have any enemies
in life you have never stood up for
anything Winston Churchill and you are
not doing it right in life if you don't
have enemies author unknown I've applied
your teachings and of trying to develop
relationships with both good and bad
leaders and or at adversaries in my life
and I feel like I do not have
enemies that makes sense cuz nak is
super nice by the way and he's and he's
really good at implementing the
principles that we talk about all the
time no's in in the game man you know
for those of you who don't know he's a
law enforcement officer he's been one
for a long time he started off in New
York City now he's in La uh you know
he's been doing that job for a long time
and that is not a job where you make
where where not making enemies is easy
yeah you know you got the political side
you got the the being out on the streets
like there's a lot of stuff going on
yeah but but okay so yeah that's no and
also real quick about no he uh so
there's this YouTube channel I came
across it on YouTube I'm not sure if it
extends beyond that but uh it's called
Soft White did you did you watch his
thing bro oh yeah watch that one with
knco soft white under that is a good one
and you kind of find out about his J his
career and who he is yeah and you get to
learn some messed up things man people
get their heads cut off and like
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Joo underground podcast so
if you want to continue to listen go to
Joo underground.com And subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us strengthen
this Legion of Troopers that are in the
game with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it cost
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized
Underground